yesterday you said this i couldn't
believe it i couldn't believe it
was it when i said it the difference and
and you know you did it with like a
little authority you know like you know
i said it with my chest didn't i i said
it with my chest the only difference is
that whole thing yeah oh he did it
between patrick mahomes
and deshawn watson they said one was
drafted by houston
and one was drafted by kansas city and
the only thing you're going to do
come strong when i'm coming off do a
little sniff at the end you know
i didn't stutter uh first of all i think
that's crazy by the way
that's crazy as the kids say show me the
lie
how about if i show you the stats the
stats matter
in context yes okay i've
since patrick mahomes came into the
[Music]
league
that's the last two years it's the last
two years
i'm not that bad it's not that bad
but you know numbers how about that but
the record though
look at the record yeah um so we have
the launching numbers
what's the by the way what's the rushing
numbers on that too gary just restaurant
properly they'll probably decide
one-sided as much as patrick mahomes
he's an incredible
runner but it's not it's not as much of
a party it kind of sounds like you're
saying
what's that and i'm not i'm not i said
kind of i'm not saying
that you're saying this but when you
start going down this path
it puts me in the in the vibe
of system not that you're saying he's a
system quarterback but you're saying
this talented quarterback in this system
has been able to thrive you're not
calling him a system quarterback but
you're kind of
hedging his success his success is
is dependent on where he is
and i guess that's true isn't isn't all
of our a lot of players
not players in life that's the truism in
life
all of our success depends upon our
circumstances
i mean we can can you say you could be a
product of your environment
i think mahomes is better because of
what we've seen
but we've only seen mahomes
be better because the circumstances are
superior
i'm saying that desean watson
look does it show does patrick mars have
a bigger arm
yeah i i've been sure to say he has a
stronger arm for whatever that's worth
let's see a better quarterback than than
uh
pat didn't sean watson's patching mom's
a better quarterback than sean watson
i don't know that to be the case i know
he's been more successful
i know he's been more successful no i'm
not going to say yes
i know he's been more successful
michael remember when game manager okay
how about this let's talk about let's
talk about evolution let's talk about
paradigm
shifts let's talk about maturation okay
all right
you remember once upon a time when
game manager was an insult
remember once upon a time when you talk
about quarterback i was just the game
manager
and then somewhere along the way we
recognize that that is the
number one job of the position is to
manage the game
right tom brady once upon a time was
called a game manager
when no actually all of them should be
game managers first and foremost
so likewise system quarterback
is viewed as some kind of an insult or
some kind of uh
you know uh it's it takes away from the
indiv their individual talent
you know what all the great quarterbacks
were throughout nfl history
they were system quarterbacks and by
system quarterbacks you know what i mean
they were put in a system that maximized
their ability
tom brady just said yesterday that he's
not the player he is
if he weren't in the new england system
i'm not talking about that's right josh
mcdaniels or charlie white system i'm
talking about the overall
organizational system you cannot take
away
joe montana you cannot extract jill
montana or steve young
from bill walsh's west or later mike
shanahan's
west coast system okay
you cannot take away um
jim kelly from the k-gun offense
like the yes they are synonymous with
their
system all true it doesn't mean that
they couldn't succeed in other systems
it just means that that that is a great
that
what do you mean because if i ask you
who's if i ask you who's a better
quarterback jim kelly or joe montana you
don't say
well it's hard no no no no no because no
no so that's not what i'm saying that's
not what i'm saying when you
i don't know what you're saying but but
no but
you said it sounded like i was
suggesting that he was a system
quarterback
or i'm not saying he's a product of his
system i'm saying andy reid and eric b
enemies
system in kansas city and the supporting
cast and the talent
i'm saying it sets patrick mahomes up
to be his best self conversely
the system in houston the the
organization
does not when it comes to desean watson
and has not
when it comes to desean watson it's why
his fellow future hall of famer j.j watt
went out of his way to say
we just wasted one of your prime years
do you think kansas city is wasting
patching my homes right now
absolutely not nope right so
i'm not i'm not in any way taking saying
that patrick holmes is just
lucky and fortunate that he ended up in
kansas city else he wouldn't be as good
somewhere else
absolutely not i would never suggest
such such a thing
i am saying poor desean watson ended up
in houston and hedy ended up somewhere
like kansas city
different story go for a different story
brett favre with mike holmgren
bradford yeah back home okay where
what's their championship do you think
they would have won the super bowl
already
yes would they be because they're on the
verge of a back to back
which hasn't happened in a long time
that's a special quarterback who does
that
yes and also if if it's just
if it's just hey they wound up in this
he wound up in houston he wound up in
kansas city
then why are we raving about patrick
mahomes so much all the records that
he's setting
and why do we have that conversation
about mahomes
like you already know it you see it when
you know you you know it when you see it
and he's going to the hall of fame we
don't talk about deshawn watson that way
should we yeah because he said he
started talking about deshaun watson too
i've just like sometimes i've referred
to him as a future hall of famer
several i don't know how many i don't
know how much more i can say i could
totally i can only control what i can
control that's what i say
and by the way my home's 526 russian
yards four touchdowns
uh the last two years desean watson 857
and 10.
so just to add to the touchdown total
look i can only control what i can what
i what i say hopefully
it makes sense and hopefully people see
where i'm coming from
i've called dishon watson a future hall
of famer i have talked about how you
can't overpay for deshaun watson
if you're a team in a trade market so i
talk about desean watson in the same
vein
but you cannot deny what patrick mahomes
and the kansas city chiefs have done the
last few years you cannot deny it
so i i think both as we fond of saying
wait for both things can be true
i think desean watson is a victim of his
circumstances
patrick mahomes is a beneficiary of his
and that
is no insult there is nothing wrong with
that
that's what you're supposed to do god
willing we all end up in circumstances
that maximize our abilities
where where the people around us ain't
holding us back so i don't
so i i think if you've watched sean
watson going back to college and in the
nfl
you see a singular talent who
unfortunately
is is is stuck in the most dysfunctional
organization in the nfl
hey thanks for watching brother from
another on youtube make sure you hit
subscribe before you leave and be sure
to watch us
3 to 5 p.m eastern time on peacock
appreciate you